journée de grève demain dans l'éducation
nationale tous les secteurs de la
maternelle à l'université devraient être
touchés par ce mouvement lancé par huit
syndicats à l'origine de la grogne des
enseignants il ya les conditions de
travail et le problème de l'emploi sans
oublier un autre point qui mobilise les
instituteurs depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant à paris en tout cas le statut
des directeurs d'école que veut modifier
le ministre de l'éducation par la
création d'une véritable hiérarchie est
elghozi et gilles de blair sont allés
voir dans une école comment ce projet
était ressentie pour vous qui est ce qui
est le responsable dans l'école à la
directrice vous attendez quoi d'elle je
pense que la direccte et celle surveille
quand même
et une maîtresse et fasse marcher son
établissement comme il faut déjà au
niveau des remplacement des profs tout
ce truc là tu vas manger bien et votre
avis et 200 pouvoir ça est-ce qu'ils
l'ont on n'en sait rien de tout ça la
grande question est là venez vous rangez
vous venez vous rangez fermeté autorités
apparemment madame la directrice a tout
pour diriger son école tout sauf
l'essentiel le pouvoir de le faire une
fois dans la place son titre officiel
institutrice chargé d'école est là pour
lui rappeler les limites de sa fonction
celle d'une enseignante parmi d'autres
plus responsables que les autres mais
seulement des tâches administratives ont
aucune mange à la cantine
je vais ajouter vous avez l'autorité sur
les enfants est ce qu'elle vous manque
cette autorité sur les m oui un peu
pourquoi et bien quand on est chef
d'établissement on est responsable de
tout l'établissement et le meneur de
l'équipe doit petit doigt peut-être
avoir une certaine autorité
vous n'avez pas non donc les situations
par exemple soit pour des problèmes
internes à l'école ou dans certaines
situations pédagogiques pédagogie le mot
est lâché et c'est sans doute sur ce
point que le projet devait créer le plus
discuté il est vrai que jusqu'ici les
grandes décisions comme le choix des
méthodes c'est elle à faire de chaque
mètre
le nouveau statut changerait tout
faisant de madame boulanger le
responsable hiérarchique là pour
superviser le travail des autres disons
que je n'ai pas besoin d'avoir un chef
pas donc je travaille dans ma place avec
les enfants les enfants qui sont en
difficulté
j'ai pas besoin d'un pouvoir hérarchie
concrètement il faudrait pas non plus
que que l'école devienne comme une
petite entreprise ou avec un
contremaître à la tête
vous changez rien ça c'est sûr c'est à
dire ça changera rien c'est à dire que
j'accepterai quand je serais d'accord
j'en suis ray koval accord un directeur
à part entière à la tête de l'école
le projet du ministre irrite les
instituteurs quant aux parents ils
découvrent avec surprise que l'école
al'inverse du collège et du lycée n'a
pas encore de chef